all right a shocking drug Discovery at
the White House sparking a blizzard of
speculation Fox News can confirm that
cocaine was indeed found in the west
wing on Sunday while President Biden and
his family were away at camp David the
Secret Service discovering the white
powder in a what they called working
area during a routine inspection it
caused a brief evacuation with fire and
emergency crews responding to a 9-1-1
call the White House weighing in today
and pointing out that there could be a
lot of suspects
where where this was discovered is a
heavily traveled area where many White
House West Wing I should be even more
specific of West Wing visitors come
through this particular area when people
visit the West Wing there is an air
there is the area of the West Wing where
it is highly traveled and that is what
happens people come through this
particular area is highly traveled I'm
just not going to get into specifics we
do have West Wing tours that that occur
here on campus they happen in this
particular past a couple of days they
happened on Friday they happened on
Saturday and Sunday
the White House also dodging questions
left and right on the cocaine caper
so what's preventing a visitor from
bringing in Anthrax or something that's
not magnetic into the White House no
look we I totally understand the
question but it is under investigation
does the White House support the
prosecution of this individual I'm just
not going to get into hypotheticals from
here with the president being satisfied
with
sir this is a busy room and we found
some cocaine and we don't know who
brought it so let's see what the Secret
Service says right how determined is the
president to get to the bottom of the
broad illegal drugs into the White House
the president thinks this is incredibly
important to get to the bottom of this
I don't know like I would I would love
to be able to say
um the president's mad and they're like
they can't do that they should blame you
totally they should say that they found
it in a my little kitty coin first for a
while I used to take one of those to the
working area of the White House
no the purse
did you see what they did though what
did they do they they it went from like
they it was found at a library highly
specific to a working area and they kept
stressing this over and over again the
possibility of suspects are endless yeah
well net will probably will probably
never get to the bottom of this one
it'll be another unsolved mystery and
our media who genuinely love to pursue a
great story when it's a republican will
not do anything on and I know that
sounds so repetitive the shoe on the
other foot thing but it is true that if
this were you know I mean like in the
last couple of weeks we've had a trans
activist bearing her breasts we find
Coke it's like If This Were it's like
they're running a you know a low rent
strip club yes but I also do love how
the media pounces on the right
for bringing up Hunter as if like he
isn't the most obvious culprit is there
somebody else we're missing media should
we be talking about kamla's laughter is
that what you would prefer but this is a
guy who leaves drugs guns and laptops
everywhere he got thrown out of the Navy
for for a Coke you got thrown out of the
Chateau Marmont it's hard to get thrown
out of the Chateau Marmont trust me I
have tried uh and then of course he was
just at the White House so I guess you
know Occam's razor this is the most
obvious thing that could happen but I
love the fact that like if you bring it
up it's like oh
typical you'd bring up Hunter what about
a Father's Love for his son right
he's an addict in recovery how dare you
and he has an addict in recovery I got
okay well that's hell of a recovery
judge she was also asked if they would
be going any of the staff within the
West Wing would be undergoing
testing drug testing watch her here
will any White House Snappers the
undergoing drug testing as part of this
investigation White House is subject to
rigorous guidelines that include drug
testing and so we will take any action
is that is appropriate and warranted
pending the outcome of the Secret
Service just not going to get into
hypotheticals from here
her ambivalence in her answer in not
answering is consistent with the
ambivalence about will the White House
prosecute why would you not say we are
going to prosecute we have to set the
the send the message here it is illegal
you don't bring it into the White House
if you're a staffer high on cocaine you
shouldn't be in the white house if
you're a staffer who brings cocaine in
you shouldn't be in the white house if
you're a tourist and how many think a
tourist would do this you think you're
going to get past the incredible
screening get past the canines get past
everything if you're a tourist and who's
going to dare you and then like once you
get through all those things then take
it out of your pocket and put it there
but the amazing thing is that Greg
touched on this for the D.C Hazmat
people said it's in the library there's
a tape recording Dana where is the
library the library is in the East Wing
where the president's family is and not
the West Wing where the public and the
Press go through but let me continue
that train of thought because I am a
prosecutor and this kind of stuff makes
me crazy number one the purpose and let
me say this Secret Service agents are
ready to take a bullet for the president
but I want to ask you the Secret Service
job is to protect the president and his
family the Secret Service is the one
that retrieved the government from uh
retrieved the gun from that basket that
garbage can outside the school the
Secret Service are the people who went
to where uh Hunter bought the gun and
tried to get the pistol permit
application that is the substance of a
crime right now away from the shop owner
but he wouldn't give it to them so here
we have a white house that wants to
manage every aspects of Our Lives what
drugs we can take what drugs we can't
take whether we should go to work
whether we should go to school whether
we should do this or that put a little
cocaine in the White House yeah we don't
want to get ahead of ourselves I mean
it's outrageous the way they responded
Joey the White House demanded a second
test because it's almost as if they're
like gosh really hope is anthrax and not
cocaine because that story is really bad
for us yeah so it's going to be really
hard for the White House to come out
strong against this person I mean just
think about it what if this person is a
staffer there they come out and say you
know what I just work really hard to
expect me to work 18 hours a day I'm
stressed out I fell into this bad habit
uh you know my my family member died it
was tragic I'm struggling to keep up
I'll become an addict I'm a victim of my
own device or my own devices and I
really I need help is what I just need
help I mean this is an Administration
that if if in no other way than through
their own silence supports the broad
Progressive policy in communities and
cities around the country that says
doing drugs is is not a bad an immoral
thing it's it's a it's a sign of
victimhood uh drug crime unfairly
prosecutes people their position as a
party from coast to coast is to is to
make excuses and to provide some sort of
redemption path for someone who does
drugs or is addicted of drugs not
provide consequence so how can you
support Gavin Newsom or his his entire
uh State on this and come out hard on
somebody that might work for you they
got caught with a little bit of cocaine
I mean they've put themselves in a place
where I don't see how they can come down
hard on them not in and not be called
out for hypocrisy by the further left
I'd like to put myself Jessica in the
shoes of any press secretary and imagine
what it would have been like on a Sunday
night of the holiday weekend when you
think I'm going to have like two days
here where I can just catch my breath
spend some time with my family and you
get the call that says hey heads up they
found cocaine in the White House well it
seemed like a joke right when I saw it
circulating on Twitter I thought it was
like the perfect July hoax
and every joke was taken before you
could get back on TV which must have
been devastating for you Greg which is
what it did like you have a a son who's
was an addict as openly in recovery
suddenly there's a little baggie of Coke
he met up with his Dad before they went
to Camp David did he slip into the
visitor place and you know just stash
something in a cubby hole like it was
all too insane but of course it riveted
by it on Sunday evening and then you
have the people who you know people are
defending the family obviously saying
it's too on the nose and the nose
whatever and then you have the people
who are out to you know get Hunter no
matter what who are you know tracing you
know it turns into one of those like the
show Homeland one of those boards where
there are red line you know red strings
connecting and then he went here and I'm
sure he talked to so and so
and it's all really just consider
concerning on a national security level
and I think that was the best question
that was asked what if Anthrax now can
get in easily how is this conceivable
that cocaine got in there if not from
someone who works in there and could get
it there are lots of cameras in the
white I don't I bet they're going to
blame it on a worker like somebody that
cleans that's what they'll do because
you know that's that's the easiest way
out is so well it was an overnight an
overnight worker but but there's a glass
scene bag other fingerprints on the bag
did they protect the bag did they
collect it in the proper way well we
know it's not Hunter because Hunter's a
man of the people he's a crack Guy this
is yeah okay this is a way too white
collar yes can you imagine though like
if you invited because on those holiday
weekends you do get a lot of friends and
family asking you can you please give us
a tour while we're in town for the for
the fireworks and so you go in on the
weekend can you imagine how many people
are calling their friends and family
going did you just screw my life over
yeah yeah because you better fess up
right now that would have been a good
thing Hunter like getting his dealer in
on a tour that's a great way to get your
drugs that's not bad it's another red
stretch exactly bring back The West Wing
show you've got writers right here on
the five I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is anyway that I know for sure
that
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now